[Music]
check
caption standout tv
plugged in freestyle let's go check it i
said the game change
ain't the same as it used to be gas
little you to carry nests like the
movies
little young boys stabbed ever so
brutally catch it on camera
violence makes the views increase this
violence it ain't new to me
i could see change it's a shame that
only few could see trap stories makes
every you
wanna do the streets i used to do the
road every day now i rebuke the streets
[Music]
you know what time it is when you're
locked away nobody's showing their
actions but got a lot to save in time to
tap into your grave i ain't forgotten
[Music]
on now man again station then walking
out it must be saying what it is
let's talk it now kid's going missing
bodies turn up with the organs out
sweet like vento but the flow can't be
watered down
i got them cautious now this time round
imma be the
[Music]
the game's gone awkward now a lot of
rappers are cowards and they talk it
down
i can't entertain this fake [ __ ] these
kids wanna prosper so they take risks
kids getting soaked on the block that
they're repping
kilo be killed they gotta walk with a
weapon no gangster they got
nash like taken it's not a game when a
life gets taken
and on the block every day there's a
homicide feel the pain when you look
into her mother's eyes
i ain't trying to be the realest but if
you're seeing what i'm seeing you will
feel this i
told you a long time then i want to
listen my own son right now
sitting in prison too many of these
youths they got hard
ears until they're sitting in the scrubs
doing hard years and the feds need
numbers for the crime rate
i stay woke so don't question my mind
stay watch my knees bearing my nephew it
got me irate 80 pound per 35 to get my
mind straight
it's the captain standout tv plugged in
you